created by Cartoon veteran Loren
Bouchard Bob's Burgers mixes silly
stories puns hearts and music to make
for a truly original and wholesome a
viewing experience get ready to dive
between the buns because we're taking a
look at the untold truth of Bob's
Burgers the way a TV show gets made is
pretty straightforward and difficult a
writer comes up with an idea for a show
writes a pilot script and if they've got
enough credits in clout in Hollywood
they've got an agent and that's agents
guests the pilots into the hands of the
executives at TV networks who decide
what shows they want to make this is not
how Bob's Burgers originated creator
Loren Bouchard was actually approached
by Susanna MCOs the executive vice
president in charge of comedy at Fox and
that's to create an animated series for
the network Marcos was working on
developing another animated series and
was looking at demo reels by animation
houses one of them included some clips
of Lucy the daughter of the devil a
McCobb comedy that had briefly run on
Adult Swim Marco's like the animation
fine but what she really lied to us a
show she thought it was funny and had an
assistant tracked down his crater Loren
Bouchard he was living in San Francisco
at the time and flew down to meet with
Marcos about making a show that same day
because cartoons are so expensive and
complicated to produce some will forego
making a complete 30-minute pilot in
favor of a pilot presentation a short
roughly animated film of just a few
minutes that gives network executives a
good idea of what a completed series
would feel like Bouchard and producer
Jim Doty Reeve made one such pilot
presentation for Fox for Center tainment
head Kevin Reilly like the overall
concept and feel of the show but II have
some notes among them without the three
kids personalities were not unique
enough from one another at that time the
Belcher kids consisted of one girl
Louise and two boys gene and Daniel
wobbly shout out to admit that Roy was
correct neither he nor Fox wanted to let
go of Dan Mintz who played Daniel the
solution changed Daniel to a girl named
Tina keep mints in the pots and don't
have him change his voice or approach to
the character at all I'm no hero and I
put my brown one boob at a time like
everyone else the last thing that
Bouchard had worked on before Bob's
Burgers was Lucy daughter of the devil
for Adult Swim that show was about the
battle between good and evil and so at
the time
Bouchard had trained himself to skew his
comedy on the more twists
site that led to a very dark initial
premise for Bob's Burgers the Belcher's
were going to run a burger joint but
they were cannibals Bouchard explained I
had this kind of more occult II sort of
darker edge to the way I was singing
then ultimately Fox loved everything
about the show except the cannibalism
Susanna MCOs talked to Bashar al Tibet
pointing out how difficult it would be
to do quote
100 episodes worth of cannibal jokes
elements of the original concept remains
mort's funeral home next door was
possibly going to be a meat supplier for
Bob's Burgers the very first episode
even plays homage the original premise
why'd you get run out of bog Harbor for
selling human flesh to the restaurant
the voice cast of Bob's Burgers was
initially populated by veteran
professional comedians and voice actors
but that's not the case for the actor
who landed the role of boisterous prone
to singing Linda Belcher singing
[Applause]
sexy part a lot of people start making
YouTube videos with visions of stardom
the dreamers only come true so far for
relative handful and John Roberts who
voices Linda is one of them his videos
such as the Christmas tree and the phone
call in which he played overbearing
older women went viral and led to
appearances on a number of shows playing
those kinds of characters such as on
Late Night with Jimmy Fallon where he
played the host mother
that's all led to a meeting with Loren
Bouchard and a role on Bob's Burgers
playing a character much like the ones
he created online in 2015 Roberts became
the first member of the Bob's Burgers
cast to earn an Emmy Award nomination
for Outstanding character voiceover
performance the show's cast consists
primarily of major players on the
alternative comedy scene such as Kristen
Schaal Dan Mintz and Eugene Mirman along
with voice acting legend hate john
benjamin also part of the cast his
academy award-winning actor and theater
star kevin kline Bob's Burgers
represents his first major voice work
for a weekly animated TV series they got
him to join the cast in a very
non-traditional way Klein's grown
children live in New York and go to a
lot of comedy shows and are big fans of
mermen in particular they brought their
father along to some shows and Kleiner
Merman got along as it turns out Klein's
manager was friends with the Bob's
Burgers casting director so the show
went out on a limb and asked him if he'd
be interested in the recurring role of
Bob's eccentric millionaire landlord mr.
fischoeder the truth is Bob I was only
raising the rent so you would notice me
really no I wanted a pool you can't get
chicks with a hedge maze sure make sense
climb read the script thought it was
funny and accepted to the apparent
disbelief of the crew
Bouchard admitted I don't think any of
us were prepared for him to say yes the
vast majority of animated TV series past
and present do not record their actors
during their voice parts all at once
rather each individual actor goes into a
recording studio and delivers lines one
by one Bob's Burgers is an exception
audio for each episode is collected from
the entire cast all at once it's not
quite a table read with microphones or
like shooting a live-action sitcom some
of the actors live in Los Angeles and
some live in New York so a high quality
ISDN line is used to unite everybody but
it is all done live with the actors
feeding off each other this gives a show
a realistic conversational feel with
plenty of
room for improvisation similar to
Bashar's previous natural-sounding
series home movies and dr. Katz
professional therapist even big
celebrities popping in for an episode
have to work this unique method of
production into their busy schedules
denizens of the Internet of a number of
theories about why youngest Voucher
child Louise always wears bunny ears
it's never quite explained why maybe she
has a bald spot she's hiding or the Hat
allows her to hide from the world in
some small way the real reason is not so
emotionally complicated it was inspired
by a manga and later anime from Japan
called Tekken King creats show creates a
Loren Bouchard explained there was a kid
who had this little bear hat and I like
that weird combination of kid and animal
when they become an animal by always
being seen wearing these little ears
you get a little cognitive dissonance we
experience Louise both as a little girl
and Bugs Bunny at the same time that's
animal instinct is alive and well in
Louise as a references to Japanese pop
culture and Bob's Burgers one episode
features an extended dream sequence
tributes to Studio Ghibli's My Neighbor
Totoro a similarly Ghibli inspired
episode that takes place inside Louise's
fever riddled brain and Baban Louise's
love of a series of Japanese martial
arts films called Hawk & chick I know
we're fighting this seaweed monster
right now but I want you to know how
much I love and support you even if you
decide hold on yeah whether or not it
has something to do with one of those
things we shot mentioned on Twitter in
2018 that the true origin of the
Weezer's bunny ear hat habit will be
explained in Bob's Burgers the movie
which hits theaters in July 2020 one of
the most popular occurring features on
Bob's Burgers it's a daily burger
special at Bob's Burgers Bob always
finds a way to incorporate new or
special ingredients to make an
interesting and tasty burger in 2015 a
Bob's Burgers fan named Cole Bowden
started a blog called the Bob's Burgers
experiment he dutifully recreated dozens
of burger of the day specials based
almost entirely on his own imagination
and culinary skills as on the show the
burgers were little more than brief
passing background gags in 2016 Bowden
teamed up with the show's creative team
to release an official cookbook the
Bob's Burgers burger book along with new
illustrations and text from the Belcher
family it includes more than 70 weel
recipes such as I know why the caged in
burger Singh's burger sweaty palms
burger and shoots out of the okay
Koral burger comes with fried okra
hollywood is full of great actors but it
takes a special life a talent to match
performers to the right path casting is
a major part of the undefinable magic of
a great TV series but the way Bob's
Burgers creates a Loren Bouchard
assembled his cast was a little
non-traditional and extremely optimistic
he wrote every main role with the actor
who would ultimately voice those
characters in mind
Bouchard told it's nice that I've worked
with John Benjamin who plays Bob for
over 20 years I've only ever done shows
of John in them I don't even want to
know what it's like to do a show without
him I knew I wanted him as a dad and we
built the family around him he thought
the female voice John Roberts did in so
many of his videos would work for Linda
Belcher and that Kristen Schaal just
ought to be Louise he's also world to
have genes Eugene Mirman before hands
wanted to include him in the main family
the only cast member not pre-approved
Dan Mintz who plays Tina and was
recommended by Benjamin new words
created by fans inspired by and starring
characters from their favorite TV shows
it's a wonderful thing but Bob's Burgers
producer and artist Tony Gennaro
loves Bob's Burgers just as much as
viewers do and makes what might be
described as fan art if he wasn't a
member of the show staff you see after
each episode script is written and
printed out for a table read by the cast
Gennaro makes a special original title
page illustration none of these images
are based on actual stills or animation
from the episode or any of its
promotional materials it's just an extra
little bit of Bob's Burgers fun strictly
for the people who make Bob's Burgers
they often mimic a movie poster or pay
homage the well-known posters used to
promote famous movies Gennaro's title
page for uncle Teddy recalls that Uncle
Buck one sheet for example while the
seaplane art is a clear sender of Top
Gun imagery Bob's Burgers scene the sea
weaves are high with the low any given
episode may present an earnest and
emotionally honest plot about the
importance of family and being a good
person but then give way to something
like Tina Belcher dreaming about sexy
zombies or a song from gene Belcher
about the glory of passing gas for
example this mix of high minded and low
minded material is prevalent in an
unexpected place an overlooked bit of
basic character information the last
name of the central characters is
Belcher why did creator Loren Bouchard
stick them with that he told it's nice
at first the quote silly stupid joke of
the name appealed to him but more
importantly it was to provide some kind
of cultural
vacation Bouchard explained my name is
french-canadian and we wanted them to
have some ethnicity but couldn't settle
on what he and the rights has led to the
name that sounded at least a little
french-canadian in addition to being a
burp joke were Belcher's from the womb
to that to check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos buy your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]